to me the cannabis has developed into
such it's this it's a great example of
community level capitalism working well
close my eyes
hi i'm tim cavanaugh a reason TV we're
here with Heather Donahue author of the
new memoir of Northern California pot
growers grow girl thanks Heather good to
have you with us and let's explain a
little bit about your history what got
you into going from being an LA actress
to going up to North in my 20s I was an
actress most notably in the Blair Witch
Project also in several other things but
that tends to overshadow the rest by the
way I think of you as really the as
manticores picture America the great
underrated Manticore which I actually
see that this was the thing about the
acting gig even while I was doing these
movies that might not have been shining
you know they made Bulgaria look pretty
much like occupation era Iraq right and
it had a good concept the concept of the
movie was that the the looting of the
Baghdad Museum had led to the unleashing
of some curse from the pagan Beast
exactly yeah the problem was the beast
was a really poor effective agent they
chose not to go the Blair Witch yeah
just saw the pieces just didn't look
right but check out Manticore but anyway
let's get back to as my career
progressed I realized I wasn't really
getting to do things that I was very
proud of or that I really wanted to put
into the world and I had this
long-standing meditation practice and
part of that was this idea of Right
Livelihood like the idea that you are
you are doing something in the world
each day and it should probably be good
I went to a meditation retreat this guy
sat down next to me introduced himself
said where you from
he said nugget town and I it was this
town that I'd been to seven years before
that I had completely fallen in love
with but I couldn't figure out what
people did for work up there so I was
like but that's amazing but what do you
do and he's a tiger pot and I thought to
myself all right sounds fascinating
so I went up and I was his apprentice
for a while and I just fell in love with
it and your authors note in the book you
noted that most all these people are
legal within the grey area created by
California law the federal government
differs with that notion how do people
feel about the way the economy and the
legal structure is changing I think
there is a little bit of a fatalistic
thing going on there things are going to
happen things are going to change and
the best position to be in is an agile
one okay so just like that hold Darwin
quote it's not the most intelligent
species that survive nor the strongest
but the ones most responsive to change I
find you're never more agile either than
when you're in a field full of pot what
do you think of the way since the
transition to the Obama administration
and the holder Justice Department it
seems as a Californian that raids are up
that medical pot tolerance is down from
even where it was before 2008 and how
has it affected people up there the
tolerance is not down among the people
in the patients we've seen lots of
dispensaries raided in LA in the last
two years right but that's not really
reflecting the sentiment of the citizens
of California even the classic NIMBYs
like the LA Weekly in the LA Times have
pretty much thrown in the towel on this
idea of dispensaries are magnets for
crime and all that garbage I mean
because there's absolutely nothing that
supports that it helps when the
dispensary is the only business that's
still open on every scorner in the
industry well there's that like I don't
understand why a city council would want
to squash thriving entrepreneurship in
such a terrible economy yeah well
because I also I also feel like when LA
was hitting its high hundreds it was
just gonna be a matter of time before
patients pardon my pun but we did them
out you know like the fly-by-night
operations were not going to be places
where say women felt comfortable going
into so eventually you're going to lose
you're going to lose that business and
you're only going to have the ones that
really are providing good patient care
that survive talk a little bit about
what you have to look forward to if
you're a farmer and you get arrested and
there are a lot of families that are
really being torn apart by prohibition
there's this woman in Oklahoma called
Patricia spotted crow who's was four
kids and she sold a $31 bag of weed
well while her kids were home and now
she's in prison and that's what just
blows my mind of why we think this
policy is working with marijuana is
still being a Schedule one drug we're
not even getting to really test it and
understand why it's working in the ways
it does there was this show called weed
wars on
discovery like a month ago and there was
this kid with really terrible epilepsy
there's a tremendous amount of anecdotal
evidence that it's really effective on
epilepsy and this family had tried
everything for their four-year-old son
so finally the father's desperate he
comes in gets a tincture of non
psychoactive high CBD strain called
Harlequin and gives it to his son the
seizures are reduced immediately why
would we not test this why would we let
families like this suffer it doesn't
make any sense
the consumer choice aspect of it you go
to the pharmacy now and they have all
sorts of varieties this one's good if
you're you know you have to do any
writing because you have so many choices
of different dispensaries you can go to
you want to go to a place that you know
is lab testing their medicine that you
know is dealing with responsible growers
that you know provides and like a
community service and it's a good
community member we don't always have
that information about some other places
that we spend our money but certainly in
the kind of business what we do to me
the kind of business has developed into
such it's this it's a great example of
community level capitalism working well
and I as much as I'm for legalization as
much as I think prohibition has created
more problems way more problems than
it's ever solved I am concerned about
broad spectrum legalization causing this
business to leave the mom-and-pop hands
that it's been in for decades
would that be because in a full
legalization environment you'd then have
to meet a bunch of new requirements as a
small grower in this weird way being in
the shadows shields you from the FDA it
shields you from the USDA or who you
know there's a million people and of
California is no slouch in terms of
finding ways to put people out of
business a mom-and-pop would not be able
to fund FDA regulations you would
completely crush the business and make
it only possible for corporations to
compete in it that's why I think looking
at how California is running this
business right now is is pretty
illuminating because it is working it is
saying the patient's want regulation the
dispensaries are responding by
self-regulating in a really responsible
way that
and come with that overriding enormous
infrastructure of something like the FDA
when you were saying before what
California has done with its pot
industry what we're really talking about
is what Californians have done on their
own really and the state to its credit
has mostly just stepped back and that's
the big that's what's made the big
difference right this is an industry
that has been for a very long time now
of the people for the people and by the
people and I would really hate to see
that change starting with George
Washington by the way the first pot
farmer yep no we're all working we're
growing cannabis it's a very useful
versatile crop absolutely yeah so useful
that it could replace a lot of a lot of
commodities that are currently produced
by very large company our sales would
not have functioned in the war of 1812
we would have lost the naval war if it
hadn't been for the hemp that we're
actually true some ways are we better
off with just with things being in the
gray area you know there's always a case
to be made for you're better off being
an outlaw than trying to stay within the
system by creating a gray area you're
actually creating a system that works
this is not an overblown system this is
this is a system on a human scale and
that's part of why it works so well this
is not outside the law this is what our
country should look like okay we should
have community level capitalism that can
be sustained by our families and our and
our people oh not these big abstract
douches whose pockets we all line sure
as a libertarian though I just have to
ask the follow-up would deregulation on
a vast scale be the way to get where
you're talking about I think because we
don't really have deregulation on a vast
scale in any sector of this economy it
would be very unfair to put the onus of
deregulation wholeheartedly on this
industry what's what's next what do you
you've written your I am NOT Spock book
that's actually really yes I guess
[__] look I have two more non-fiction
books that I'm developing an anomaly
because the publishing industry is in a
little bit of trouble
I'm also developing it for television
grow girl for television all those years
in flat Hollywood didn't tell you that
the writers are lower than well crap
yeah but it all works out fine as long
as you don't live in LA
what's great talking to you Hank it's on
you author of girl girl for reason TV
I'm Tim cabinet